c'est un drapeau qui date de la fin du
xviiie siècle d'ailleurs 1766 un décret
de la royauté française réponse à tous
les bâtiments à tous les bâtiments de la
marine marchande qui naviguait vers la
martinique et vers sainte luce il faut
savoir qu'à cette époque sainte russie
était encore dans le giron de la royauté
française
il est lié au commerce triangulaire
parce que il le permettait dans les
ports
europe et enfin dans les ports français
nantes bordeaux et cetera ils
permettaient de reconnaître les
bâtiments les bateaux qui s'adonnait à
ce commerce triangulaire je crois que ça
nous concerne les ans est donc et c'est
normal je trouve ça y est favorable à ce
que ça devienne l'emblème de lamartine
troqué oui madame oui ce qui serait
peut-être plus intéressant ça serait
d'utiliser le drapeau femmes l'emblème
de la région c'est vraiment neutre
je trouve que c'est vraiment neutre et
je trouve beau quand même il ya le gall
marching dessus l'impression d'avoir un
oiseau qui flottent par dessus c'est
c'est très bien fait seule fois qu'elle
doit pour peut changer oui sous français
vous pensez que la martinique n'a pas
besoin donc c'est à dire qu'on vous dit
votre apogée lequel vous pensez auquel
s'est plus les blogs les serpents
celui-là vous ils vous dérange pas vous
pensez que ça pose